five and you're set up for a very
standing combo so i don't know i mean
this game's been out for five years but
still a lot of uh tech out there to be
discovered in a lot of like techniques i
feel like yeah it's completely different
from what you would see from normal 2d
games where you know akuma could jump
and hit a button on the landing crane
but in this instance he jumped and he
didn't talk to to get into a jungle
state and i thought that was pretty sick
four
maybe lemons like to go low after that
minus 10 moves
follow up here he has the wall
oh but a big counter hit he knew a
button was coming out
he goes for a mix-up instead
and the running need to follow up oh oh
my gosh that missed everything the
evasiveness from that back 33
unfortunate there oh my god everything
is missing what is happening here
man three
you know if you're in his shoes you're
like man this guy hasn't done it all
will he do it this round is he gonna do
it and will he even do it at all
four four threes instead what's gonna
happen it's incredibly scary to be at
this position right now look at where
he's going three straight electrics you
know he's
oh my god the one time he does it you
were talking about his etiquette when is
it gonna come out and it came out and
unfortunately he lost half of his life
obviously energy mark was right there
with us in that thought process he knew
he's keeping track and that's why he's
the evil champion
oh no back to the wall you have to be
careful this is going to hurt you went
for the launch mark on my ball
oh he's dead
that sucks he went for the drive but he
got counter hit a 4-3 for his trouble
two
once we heard both tracks we knew man
that was debated so he's losing in the
match right when he fought um against
joe starr of a comeback being made but
again
he's going in man
as well yeah we might as well give them
three perfect for that one
zero or divine exorcist will tie it up
this is an important round
a lot despite divine having this
game so far gets energy it might not
matter energy if it goes up to zero here
you know there might be no looking back
yeah
you're gonna have to be very careful
miguel and rachel is a deadly monster
watch out
oh and he knew there was a gap in
between he was able to snuff it out
[Music]
[Music]
you